what i see happening here in the united
states
in particular with this election and
you've said that you would support
biden if you were an american citizen i
said i supported trump
what's happening that i can see and it's
a very clear
i think microcosm of what we've been
talking about
say for example the media has already
called the election for biden
and essentially that
political group believes that biden
is president-elect yet we have
a number of voting inconsistencies
primarily because there was a lot of
voting by mail
which has been shown to be fraught with
fraud
and there's going to be a number of
legal challenges to the vote on the
basis of
there was either dead people counted or
there were
votes from people that don't exist or
don't actually live in the state
whatever the
issue is there is there is a
disagreement on the vote so
how do we reconcile in the united states
the fact that we're going to have a
group that believes that they won the
election
and then we may go through a legal
process that says no in reality
somebody else won the election
here we're fighting a narrative here
we're
basically going along with
the rule of law how how do you think
americans
can come together and reconcile this
idea because
what i see going on right now is the
media has completely
basically gone over to one side in the
united states and i don't know what the
uk media is like but
when we when you talk about a plurality
of ideas there is not a plurality of
ideas
in the american media sphere today it is
one
cited completely now a lot of that has
to do with i think
animosity for the president but how do
we reconcile that
as a nation where you may have a legal
process that goes through and determines
somebody else's president but you have
this this na this process of the
narrative that is creating
this alternative view how do we
reconcile that because i think
what you have brought in cynical
theories is
clarity to the problem but this is
becoming acute in our own society
right now like with in this election
so there's going to be an objective
truth
with the election if fraud has taken
place then obviously a
rigorous investigation needs to take
place
in the worst case scenario a new um
and more secure voting um sort of a
system has to has to happen there's an
objective truth here this isn't a matter
of narratives i'm i'm somewhat skeptical
that the entire media is um
going one side because i i think the
last time i
i looked the most popular news outlet is
still
fox you don't know what happened
recently so
fox was the first to call arizona
so all of its viewers are absolutely
up in arms because they believe
and there's been this slow uh
progression of fox news basically moving
more towards the rest of the um the mess
the rest of the you know msnbc cnn
all of the others and it's really broken
just in the last since
fox news was the first to call arizona
before the ballot all the ballots had
been counted
there's a lot of anger and
disappointment in that so yes i would
agree that fox news was
but just in this election alone there's
been a complete shift
people are abandoning the channel in
fact recently cnn and msnbc
had more viewers than fox news which was
completely upside down so
um that that's happening like literally
right now which is why i say it's so
acute
i i certainly think there is that
dominant narrative problem
going on i i think there there are other
narratives in the us
as well though i hear a lot from from
conservatives who have their
their own very strong um narrative which
isn't
um always all that healthy or based on
evidence and reason either so i i
i still believe that the what the way
forward is for those of us on the left
or the right to focus on
liberalism to try and address the
problem on our own side now this is why
i have stayed
on the left and that's because i think i
have to fight
that problem within the left from the
left
and i appreciate and respect ethical
conservatives who see
the problem on the right so i um
i'm in favor of quite a lot of the the
never trumpers
who saw him as um what
i i think has been accurately described
as a postmodern president
he's a very similar kind of problem
um epistemologically when when it comes
to how to
to knowledge and narratives that we're
seeing on the postmodern left
my my hope and i might be idealistic
here
is that liberal and evidence-based
leftists can push out the social justice
and liberal and evidence-based um
rightists can push out the populists and
and the grown-ups can
can talk and we can have two parties
again
who aren't based on um extreme
narratives and trying to win a war of
them now if you're asking me how to
achieve that and how to achieve it in
america
i'm not going to be um
i'm not going to be a miracle worker
here i have some plans for the uk
i think we are not quite where you are i
think we can pull back
i'm i'm quite scared for america at the
moment i'm
i'm afraid that that what is happening
is a genuine occult attempt at a
cultural
revolution and my fear is that it it
could in its worst
case lead to something that's almost
like a civil war
so i don't know how um you
you can avoid that i do think
that you need ethical um leftists in
there to really hold
biden to his promise to be the president
for all americans and to try and push
that social justice
out of the left